(loud whoosh)
(bang)
- What's up, Believe Nation?
It's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is that
if you see in you what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today I'm going to talk about
seven ways to make money as a teenager.
- [Narrator] Nine.
Eight.
(techno music)
Seven.
- So I know I have a lot of young people
watch my YouTube channel.
I love it.
I wish YouTube was around
when I was a teenager
trying to get started as an entrepreneur.
And I wanted to make this video today
to share how you can get started,
how you can make money as a teenager,
and start seeing some
real business success
and some results to achieve your goal
and not have to go get
that typical corporate job
that you may not want to do.
So today, I'm going to
share some of the things
that I actually did when
I was getting started
as a teenage entrepreneur,
but also some of the
things that I would do
if I was starting again now.
So I'm 37 right now.
If I was starting up again,
what I would do today.
(rhythmic music)
Tip number one is, understand
where you can bring value.
So the most important business rule
that you need to understand is
where you can bring value to people
is where you're going to make money.
The more value you can bring to somebody,
the more money you're going to make.
It's the most important rule about money.
So I'll be thinking about,
where can I bring value
to the people around me,
to companies that I know,
to people that I know?
What major problem have
I solved for myself
that may be valuable for other
people out there, as well?
And I'd be looking for opportunities
where youth is an advantage.
Because in some industries,
youth is a negative.
You don't have the experience.
But in some industries,
youth is an advantage.
This did not exist 20 years ago.
Even when I was getting
started 10 years ago.
Wait, how old? 19.
My first company I was 19, so almost 10,
no, almost 20 years.
I'm getting old.
I'm getting old, guys.
37, so 19, so 20 years ago, pretty much.
Youth was still seen as a negative,
like, "You don't know
what you're talking about.
"You have no experience.
Now it's starting to change in
a lot of different industries
where youth is a benefit,
and if you can solve
a problem for yourself
or bring value to somebody else,
then that's a quick path to
be able to make some money.
So understand the value that
you can bring to people.
(rhythmic music)
Tip number two is start
an online business.
This is what I did.
And when I was at the very beginning,
my first company, again, I'm 19 years old,
I was actually really concerned
about selling to people,
selling face to face,
selling over the phone.
My voice sounded really young.
I was selling to people who had PhDs
who were three times my age.
And on one side it was a limiting belief.
All they really cared about was that
I could provide them with some value,
back to point number one.
But starting the online
business allowed me
to do something that I was good at.
We understood websites.
We understood how to sell online.
It was something that
people who were older.
Think about this.
This was 20 years ago, too.
The idea of having a website
is not anything revolutionary right now.
But starting an online business
in a field where you
can bring more expertise
than people who are three times your age,
four times your age, maybe,
is something that you
can do as a young person
to bring a lot of value.
So I started online with the website.
We started selling internationally.
We started selling to companies,
again, around the world, internationally.
And so I would encourage you
to look at online opportunities
that fit your skill set, again,
where you can bring value.
So not just typical
fill out a survey and make some money
or do some boring data entry job.
I'd be looking at, what are you great at,
and then how can you
bring that service online?
(rhythmic music)
Number three, I would look
at hustle versus experience.
In some businesses, you need to do
a lot of hustle to stay on top of the game
to really understand
how things are working,
and in some business, you need to have
a lot of experience to understand
how it has historically worked
so you get a sense of your
success in that field.
And so you're going to
have a hard time competing
in the businesses and industries
where experience really,
really, really matters.
So if you want to be a lawyer,
you kind of have to understand
the whole legal system.
If you want to be a really great leader,
you have to understand all
the leadership training,
have gone through actually
leading people before.
If you want to be a great speaker,
you have to put in the reps.
You have to do a lot of work
to be great at speaking.
It's not that you can't do it.
It's totally achievable.
If you have a big goal
and you are working on
it every single day,
you can pass people who are
more experienced than you.
It's just a harder road to climb
if you want to get into an industry
where experience really matters
versus ones where hustle really matters.
So as an example,
the first thing I did when
I sold my first business
was I went to go work with
a venture capital company.
I was curious about the industry.
To have all the
connections in the industry
takes time to build up.
So what I did was I connected with people
who already had those connections
and I offered to come
in and hustle with them.
So my role was to,
I wanted to learn the
venture capital industry.
I wanted to learn from these guys.
And my role was to go out
and drum up new business.
And so I was talking to
new potential entrepreneurs
who wanted to raise capital,
who needed to grow and to expand,
and then I relied on
my four partners there
to be able to provide the
credentials, the experience,
the connections, the
knowledge, the expertise,
all the things that had to
do with running a business
that they can give the advice,
where my role was the hustle role.
So your advantage as a young
person is you can hustle.
You can out-hustle, you can out-work
a lot of the people who are older
who may have other responsibilities,
who may just not care as much about it.
I look at YouTube as a great example.
One, it's a newer medium,
so a lot of the older people
aren't even on YouTube.
A lot of the great speakers of the world
are barely on YouTube.
That gives opportunities for people
who are not as great at speaking.
I'm not as great at speaking
as a lot of people who
have come before me.
But because they're not on
YouTube or not nearly as much,
I can win.
And so the same thing for you guys.
YouTube, people complain about
YouTube's algorithm update
changing all the time.
That's great for you.
All the social media networks
with their algorithms
changing all the time,
it really promotes somebody
who loves to hustle
versus somebody who has experience.
So what worked on YouTube five years ago
doesn't work as well as it does right now.
The idea of having consistent content
and looking at watch time
versus what YouTube cared about
before makes a difference.
Every time there's a new update,
all you hear about are people complaining.
"I can't believe Facebook did this.
"I can't believe YouTube did this.
"I can't believe Google did this."
And they complain, and they
complain, and they complain,
because all the experience that
they gained is now useless,
or at least has been diminished.
It's not as helpful to them anymore.
Where the value is in the hustle,
the figure out the new thing.
I look at it in the
e-sports world, as well,
where when Riot introduces
a new patch for League of Legends,
we're going niche now in e-spots,
but I love League of Legends,
there's always changes
that happen in the game.
And the teams that win are the ones
that adapt to the changes fastest.
You have to constantly be adapting
to the changes that are happening.
And if you just rely on your experience
then you're going to fall apart.
The way that League of
Legends was played last year
is different than it's played right now.
And that applies to some industries
more rapidly than other industries.
So if you want to be
the next great personal
development coach, you can do it.
It's just a ton of work,
and the guys like Tony
Robbins are ahead of you,
so it's going to be hard to
replace him or all the other people
'cause they have tons of
experience behind them.
But in other industries
where the hustle is more
important than the experience,
you can get to number one
really, really quickly.
(rhythmic music)
Tip number four is go
all in on your strengths.
What you want to do is focus on
the thing that you are great at.
What do you love doing?
How do you love spending your time?
And try to provide value
in that specific niche
as much as possible.
So for example, me.
If I was starting all over again,
if I'm a teenager or I'm in high school
or I'm just starting university
and I'm trying to figure out,
"What business do I want to go into?"
I would look at online marketing.
'Cause I love online marketing.
I don't want to tell you guys
to get into online marketing.
You got to find the thing.
Getting into online marketing
because I tell you to
is the stupidest reason ever.
You want to go into the thing
that you have a passion for,
that you're consuming,
that you're learning,
you're digesting, as much as possible.
I love online marketing.
And so I would go and
learn everything about
whatever platform I was using most.
I use the YouTube the most
right now as a 37 year old,
and so I would look at
YouTube as the place
where I would want to
learn as much as I could.
And really, to understand
the YouTube algorithm and
to start to win there,
you could understand
everything you needed to know
about the YouTube algorithm in a day.
By consuming lots of
other people's content
and looking at the experts and
seeing what they have to say,
you could know more than
99% of YouTubers in one day.
You couldn't do that in another industry
where experience is
super, super important.
And then I'd be looking at,
how can I provide that
value to somebody else?
How could I approach a
YouTuber who I look up to
and say, "Listen, I love your channel.
"I love all your content.
"I watch it every day.
"There are some key
things that you're missing
"that I'd love to help you
with and provide value on."
And I would do it for free at the start,
one, to gain some experience
and credibility and recognition,
but also, if you're providing
a good service for them
and they like it, they're
going to want to hire you to,
say, go in and help them with
a couple of their videos,
and it works, because
you've done the research
and they're seeing a result.
You're providing value.
What do you get for providing value?
You get paid.
You get money.
And so if you were providing
insane value to a YouTuber
and their channel is exploding,
they're going to want
to keep you on board.
Now, the first person you do it for,
they may not want to keep you on board.
They may want to steal your
idea and do it all themselves.
They may not have seen results,
in which case you didn't do a good job.
But if you do that a couple times,
you're not going to get 10 people all say,
"I'm just going to steal from you
"and I'm going to pay
you for your service."
And so it may not work the first time,
it may not work the second time,
but the third, fourth, or fifth time,
it's going to work eventually,
and you'll find the people
who really value what you do.
And once you're in,
you can build a long term
relationship with them.
You'll get referrals.
You'll be able to grow this business out.
And so I would focus on YouTube.
But for you, maybe it's Instagram.
Maybe it's Facebook.
Maybe you love Twitter.
Maybe it's musical.ly.
And find the other people who
you can look at in that market
who are having success but
could be doing way better,
or helping port people to a new market.
If somebody is big on YouTube like me
but isn't doing as much on Snapchat,
maybe you're the Snapchat king.
Maybe you understand
everything about Snapchat
and you're on top of
every algorithm update
and you're on top of every filter
and every strategy and every idea,
and you love my content
and there's a way that you can
help me explode on Snapchat
and turn a real ROI on that, talk to me.
Let's see how we can
make something happen.
That's the game that you
want to start to get into.
That's what I would do if I
was starting over right now.
(rhythmic music)
Tip number five is start small.
This is one of the hardest things to do,
because I remember being 19 years old
and having big ambitions
and wanting to do big things
and then being frustrated
with slow progress and slow results.
A lot of people put in so
much energy at the start
and then they burn out,
and they never really had a chance
to let their business grow,
where starting a company
does take some time.
It's not for lack of effort
or lack of hustling or lack of work.
It just doesn't happen the
next week or the next month.
You've got to put in consistent work.
If you look at
any successful entrepreneur
that you look up to,
they put in consistent,
consistent, consistent work.
So I'd be looking at,
what do I need to do to start
small and take daily action?
That may even mean go get a part time job.
Go get a job working at,
now, if you're going to get a job,
it's not just to earn money but to learn.
If you want to know YouTube inside out,
go work for a YouTuber
who's having success
that you look up to.
If you want to learn digital marketing,
go work for a digital marketing company
that has 10 employees or less
and take on as much as you can
to really learn that business.
You're getting paid to learn the industry.
So that may be an option.
And start on the side.
Research as much as possible.
Hustle every day.
Reach out multiple times
to people every single day.
And eventually, those are
going to turn into wins.
But you're going to get a lot
of fails, a lot of small nos,
over and over and over and over again,
and most people just quit too soon.
Most people, you may reach out
to 10 people and you get 10 nos
or really you have to
reach out to 500 people.
You're just not putting in enough reps.
So start small,
and understand that with
patience and dedicated action,
you're going to grow.
(rhythmic music)
Tip number six is model success.
One of the great things about any business
is you can reverse engineer it.
If somebody has figured out how to do it,
if somebody looks like
you and has had success,
you can do it, too.
A lot of young entrepreneurs came online
because they saw Mark Zuckerberg
and Facebook take off.
They see this young guy
becomes a billionaire
and gets everybody's respect,
so if he can do it, I can do it, too.
And so if there's somebody
that looks like you
who's made it, you can make it, too.
And being surrounded by
that I think is important,
because young people more
and more and more and more
are getting respect in the business world
because you can provide real value,
but you may not feel it from
your immediate environment.
Your parents might think you're crazy,
like, "What are you doing?
"You want to be a gamer?
"What are you talking about?
"You can't make money on video games."
The people around you who are older
who grew up in a different generation,
they love you, and they're
looking out for you,
but they may not understand
how today's economy really, really works.
And so it's hard to stay
dedicated to that thing
that you really want to do
when everybody around you is so negative.
And so create a better
environment for yourself,
modeling success.
Modeling success is what saved my company.
I was 19.
I wanted to quit.
I told my partner, "I quit."
And looking at Bill Gates
and how he started Microsoft
gave me a strategy that
I can use for my company,
and we started to make money.
And so that really
helped save my business.
You could do the same.
It's even easier now because
there's people to reach out to,
people who are doing live hangouts,
people who you can send
an Instagram message to
and they're going to write back to you.
I wish hangouts was a thing when I was 19.
I was still going to libraries
and studying at libraries and
getting research from books.
Books are still great, I have my own,
but I wish I had the Internet.
I wish I had people
that I can connect with.
I do hangouts almost once
a week on my channel.
You can reach me.
You can reach Gary Vaynerchuk.
You can reach other business leaders.
You can reach people on Twitter.
You can connect with people
and ask real questions
and get feedback on it.
So I would use that to my advantage.
You know, being a young person
gives you that advantage
where people want to give back.
If it seems genuine,
if it seems authentic,
if it feels like you really
want to make this thing happen,
people like giving back because
they see themselves in you.
They see, like if you write to me,
anytime somebody writes to me, is like,
"Hey, I'm a 13 year old entrepreneur,"
I think of myself at 13.
It's like, "Man, how awesome would it be
"to be able to reach out to somebody
"who's accomplished more
than me when I was 13
"and get direct feedback?"
And so doing the work.
If you're going to ask
for questions, though,
ask for one question.
Don't ask for a million questions.
One question, and then do the work.
Do not come back to that same
person, ask another question,
until you did the work
on the first thing that you asked for.
Otherwise, you're wasting their time.
(rhythmic music)
And then tip number seven is
create a great environment.
And I talked a little bit about that
on the modeling success,
but you have people around
you who are discouraging you,
and you're trying to do
one of the most difficult
things in the world,
which is start a business.
It's no joke.
It's not an easy, overnight thing.
There's a lot of dedicated
work that has to go into it,
and if you have people around you
who don't support your vision,
it's really hard to get that going.
And so I'd be looking at my environment,
my physical environment,
like where are you working?
Working out of your bedroom?
Great.
What's on the walls?
What are you looking at every day?
What inspires you?
What's your morning routine?
Ever day, you need to start your morning
with something that inspires
you, makes you feel like
you can be an entrepreneur
and have success,
whether that's watching one of my videos,
reading a book, watching
somebody else's videos,
tuning into somebody's
Snapchat, whatever it is,
whatever the thing is that
gets you feeling confident
that I can go out and do this,
do that every single morning.
Because otherwise, you're
going to get too discouraged.
You're going to have moments
of excitement and, "I can do anything,"
and then you're going to fall back down
and you're not going to work for a week
because your parents are hating on you
or your friends are hating on you
or your teachers say you're
never going to do anything
in the entrepreneurship world.
So having that daily, consistent action
to make you feel bold, confident,
powerful, entrepreneurial
is super important.
Whatever that thing is that
gets you juiced and motivated,
every single morning, start with it.
And it can't be the same video.
Like the same video or the
same song will phase out.
You could watch this video
once and be motivated,
the next day, a little bit more motivated,
and then it'll start to,
it's going to fall off.
So you need a source.
That's why I make videos daily,
because there's always something new
for people to digest and consume
and feel good about themselves
on and learn something from.
But if it's an author you like,
read a different book of theirs.
You go through a couple pages a day.
Or again, somebody who's
consistent on Snapchat.
It's not about that one snap
six months ago that they did.
It's the next one that they do
and the next one that they do.
So having that constant source
of new motivation for you every single day
and starting your day with
it is super important.
So those are my seven
tips on how to make money
as a teenage entrepreneur.
Thank you so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know, which
was your favorite tip?
What did you enjoy the most?
Did I miss an eight, nine, 10,
that you want to add to the list?
Leave down in the comments.
And if you respond and leave a comment
in the first few hours
after this video went live,
you have a chance to win
one of our two daily prizes.
I made this video because
Moises Molina asked me to.
If you want to vote on
the next Top Seven Ways
video I should make,
check out the link in the description.
You can go there, give
out your suggestions,
and maybe you'll get lucky.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Shlomo Awoke.
Thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
taking that picture, posting to Instagram.
I really appreciate it.
I see that my book is on the left side,
and so I'm assuming you're
reading from left to right,
and so that would be awesome
as a first choice to read on that list.
But thank you so much again for sharing,
and I really hope you enjoy the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(loud whoosh)
(bang)